Well, the fallout continues
tonight for President Biden
and White House
staff over the mishandling
of classified information
and lack of transparency.
CNN senior political commentator
Adam Kinzinger joins us now with more.
So, Adam Reuters.
Jeff Mason says this probe, quote,
has neutralized Democrats ability
to target former President Trump.
Former Obama
adviser David Axelrod
calls it a huge gift to Trump.
What's your take?
Yeah, I think they're right.
It's a huge gift.
So there's the legal side
and there's the political side.
The legal side will be
the legal side can do nuance.
They'll be fair.
They'll go through
the Donald Trump thing,
the Joe Biden thing, and go after it
the right way politically.
Basically, this is taken out,
I think, almost any ability
for Democrats
to go after the former
president on this issue.
Still,
there is still a January 6th thing
that happened,
which I think is important
to keep in mind.
And it's really about me.
The other thing is that
I think one of the biggest problems
has been
the continuing
revelation of new documents.
And they've not done a good job
of putting together how that happened
or they continue it finding new batches.
Did they happen upon it?
And I think politically,
it's pretty bad at the moment.
Yeah.
When they released the first statement
talking about the batch in November,
it failed to mention the second batch
that was found in December.
So then they had the
reporters found out about it.
They released another statement.
So there are certainly fair questions
about a lack of transparency
from the Biden White House.
But let's listen to what House
Oversight Chairman
James Colmer said to me in November
regarding the classified documents
found at Trump's residence and Mar a Lago
I don't know much about that.
That's not something that
we've requested information
just to see what was going on,
because I don't
know what documents were at Mar-A-Lago
So, you know,
that's something
we're just waiting to see
what comes out in that.
But is it fair to say
that investigation won't be a priority?
That will not be a priority.
Okay.
So that was about Trump.
And now this is what he said
earlier today
about the Biden investigation.
At the end of the day.
My biggest concern
is that the classified documents,
to be honest with you,
my concern is how
there's such a discrepancy
in how former
President Trump
was treated by raiding Mar
a Lago, by
getting the security cameras,
by taking pictures of documents
on the on the floor, by going through
Melania's closet versus Joe Biden.
They're like,
okay, your personal lawyers,
you don't have security clearance.
They can go through.
They can just keep looking
and keep
looking and,
you know, determine whatever is there
that's not equal treatment.
What do you make of that?
Well, first off,
thank you for keeping that
and playing it,
because I think this is very important
for people to see
as, frankly, the hypocrisy that exists.
And secondarily,
it's a very different situation.
I think a lot of people forget that
Mar a Lago was raided
only after repeated engagements
with the government.
They said, we know you have this,
they know they've moved it.
They've said we don't have it.
And that's what led to this.
So it's a different situation.
But as Mr.
Komar is doing
and doing quite well,
if you throw enough stuff on the wall,
it creates a lot of confusion.
But but I think the bottom line
is anybody, whether you're a Republican
or a Democrat talking about this issue,
you should be consistent
with what you said
about Donald Trump as well.
There are differences, you can note that.
But this is one of the
things that drives me
and I think a lot of Americans
crazy is open, obvious
and almost a disregard
for whether or not something you say is
not consistent with what you say
with a different party.
Just be consistent. Uphold the law.
We can't have classified information
out there
and investigate
Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
Right.
And that was I remember
when Republicans came out
so strongly defending Trump at that time.
It was notable.
And then here you are in a situation
where the same thing
is happening with President Biden
in terms of
classified documents
being not where they should be.
And suddenly
they've had to change their tune.
Right into
it is interesting and important to note.
You've had some pretty dire things
to say
about the future of your party,
especially after the speaker fight.
And I'm curious,
have you ever considered
switching parties
to become an independent
I mean, those are kinds of thoughts.
You frankly
go through my head
all the time about, you know,
what is the future
of the Republican Party?
What's you know,
how do I identify
when it comes to the politics of this?
I'm still a believer that, look,
I think
even though things are still continuing
to go off the rails
with the Republican Party,
there are signs with the lessening
of Donald Trump's influence,
although I think people have
learned Trumpism,
there is signs
that some of this may
eventually burn itself out.
And so I'll never say
I quit considering it, because for me
and I think that's
how most Americans feel, is like
you just want to be represented
by somebody.
And in my case,
the Republican Party
has certainly felt like it's left me.
I would change my policies, my beliefs
or anything.
I just believe in truth.
And I believe in being committed
to truth and consistency and honesty.
And that's where I feel
a little homeless
in the Republican Party sometimes.
But you still identify as a Republican.
What would be the final straw for you?
I think it's like when it happens,
that'll be the final straw.
When, you know, you know, look, it's
we are still a country represented
by two political parties generally.
And obviously, there's minor parties.
And I think the Republican Party
still deserves a fight
for the soul of it.
But, you know,
at the same time,
I think most Americans feel like I'm
kind of tired of voting
for lesser of two evils.
And so right now, I'm
enjoying not being in Congress,
and I'll continue
to evaluate that with myself. Every day.
Well, let's talk about a Republican
that is in Congress right now,
and that would be
the New York Congressman,
George Santos,
who has lied about his identity
The voters put him in office
based on an identity that he made up.
And we're getting more
and more evidence
of everything he made up,
it seems like, by the day
here is the latest example.
This was a radio interview he did
where he fabricated
playing on a volleyball team,
going to Baruch College
and getting surgery. Let's listen
You know,
it's funny, I actually went to school on
on a volleyball scholarship. I did.
I know what I did.
Yeah,
when I was in Peru,
we were the number one volleyball.
You graduate from the.
Did you graduate from there?
Yeah. So did I did. I did. So did I.
Very cool.
A great school, great institution.
Very good. Very good.
I look, I sacrifice both my knees
and got very nice. Knee replacement.
Knee replacement from outside
playing volleyball.
That's how serious I took the game.
Again, a ally.
Your thoughts?
And you don't serve me, by the way.
Kevin McCarthy.
Oh, go ahead.
I just want to note to our viewers,
he is still serving
Kevin McCarthy has said he has no plans
to ask him to resign, but go ahead.
Although other Republicans have.
Yeah,
I mean, look, Kevin
can't ask him to resign
because Kevin needs his vote
as it is right now.
I really worry about the Republicans
ability to pass anything.
I worry about the country's ability
to pass something through the debt limit.
This guy is not just
expanding his resume.
He's not lying about some things.
I mean, truthfully,
he is a total utter fraud in his election
in front of the people of New York
was fraudulent.
He presented himself
as somebody he wasn't.
Look, I don't think he
I don't think he can make it
two years in Congress
just personally
I mean, Congress can kick him out,
by the way.
Congress can certainly censure
it. Yeah. Yeah.
There has to be a big majority.
And I think if Kevin came out
and was for it, they would do it.
But Kevin McCarthy needs his vote.
This I feel bad
for the 700,000 people in New York
that he represents, that
he utterly,
absolutely, completely lied to.
So then.
Okay,
so so clearly you have issues with him,
but what is your message to Kevin
McCarthy then about this?
Well, I mean,
look, if I was
there, I'd tell Kevin, we have to
we have to ask, what are we?
We have to ask him to resign.
Look, his own
party back in New York
has said we want him out.
I think, you know, if Kevin came out
and said this,
the leadership of the GOP
in the House, Senate,
he would maybe he still wouldn't resign.
But I certainly think the pressure
would be there.
Look,
my party has a problem
with telling the truth.
This is not helping that reputation.
And that's what I'd be advising.
But it's obvious he's not going to do it
because he needs that vote.